In movies or TV,
whenever one character says to another
character,
can't we just go back to the way things
used to be?
It's usually a sign on the part of the
writers that that character has yet to
face up either to reality or to
themselves.
The cliche is offered up as a solution.
Some trauma has passed parties that were
enraged or hurt or a mistaken one to
forgive or heal or apologize.
They want the bad times to give way to
good times,
but only on the pretense,
the false pretense that the bad times
never happened.
This is a kind of red herring of
reconciliation.
We know that trauma can be repressed,
but it can't be erased.
Lasting reconciliation is achieved by
emotional self awareness,
by embracing the change agents of trauma
and how they irreversibly reorganize
elements of personality,
identity and social reality.
This idea,
the idea of embracing our wounds,
our brokenness is manifested quite
politically in the Japanese mending
practice of consumer,
literally meaning golden joinery.
Consume.
D is the art of fixing broken pottery
with lacquer,
resin,
dusted or mixed with powder goal.
Asian cultures have a long history in
lacquer ware,
though it matured into a sophisticated
art in the Chinese Shang Dynasty.
The earliest discovered lacquered object
dates to the Neolithic Himoutu culture
in the fifth millennium,
BC older than the earth itself.
According to young Earth creationists,
pretty impressive.
It could be alien,
the various delicate arts of lacquer
ware,
ramified and expanded down millenniums
and cultures.
The story of consumer reportedly begins
in the 15th century with the Japanese
military commander.
The story goes that famous Shogun
Ashikaga,
Yoshi.
Masa broke one of his prize Chinese tea
bowls,
so he sent the item back to China for
repair.
What he got in return was his bowl
mended with bulky and ugly metal staples
dismayed,
Yoshi,
Masa prompted Japanese craftsmen to
search for a more aesthetic means of
repair.
The Art of keen,
Suki became famous for turning broken
objects into pieces more beautiful than
the original product.
There are even rumors of people breaking
their own possessions on purpose so that
they can be mended using this lovely
technique.
The philosophy here follows from abroad
or Japanese aesthetic called Wabi,
Sabi that finds beauty not in
traditional western ideals of symmetry
or geometry,
but in Buddhist concept of impermanence
and imperfection.
The fracture is on a ceramic bowl.
Don't represent the end of that object's
life,
but rather an essential moment in its
history.
The flaws of a shape aren't hidden from
inspection,
but in blaze with golden significance.
Maybe Hemingway had consumed pee on his
mind when he wrote that famous line from
a farewell to arms.
The world breaks everyone and afterward
many are strong in the broken places.
The amazing art of consuming a fading
art like so many handcrafts symbolizes
the truth.
That repair requires transformation.
That pristine is less beautiful than the
broke,
and that the shape of us is impossible
to see until it's fractured until the
wound,
like a crack runs.
It's like,
hey everybody,
thanks for watching.
[inaudible] is just another example of
the profound differences in western and
eastern aesthetics and thought.
There's not too much to read about it
online,
but every article that I found,
I'll put in the description below under
work cited and you can check it out
there.
Thank you to everybody who followed me
on twitter following last week's video.
That was awesome.
Um,
if you haven't,
please do also your comments on the
videos have been amazing and I'll try to
continue to respond to all of them.
But if you do want to have a more
involved discussion,
go to Mike Tumbler page and use the ask
me anything feature and I'll be able to
respond in a sort of deeper,
more thoughtful way.
And is always throw this video up on
Reddit if you found it interesting.
Um,
reddit has been awesome and I will see
you next time.